do writers want to control their story
world and if so what should they accept
is out of their control so there's a
couple different schools of thought I
guess the writers seem to have you've
got writers who think that they are God
and all these characters most bowed to
their win because they're the ones
selling the story I'm kind of one of
those writers there are other writers
who let the story tell itself where they
they you know basically sit back and
they're just like unraveling as the
characters are coming up with the ideas
I find that the people in the second
group who were just letting the story
tell itself are also the ones who don't
outline and may get lost in the trenches
along the way I'm a serial outliner I
will not start page one until I have a
bulletproof story I will do my outline
and then do a rewrite on the outline
that you'll rewrite on the outline until
like the story as flawless as I can
personally make it before I even start
writing the script and then I'm just
adding dialogue basically at that point
so I have complete control over
everything things might change a little
bit in the drafting like if something
doesn't work once I'm actually writing
up the longer version of it then I might
make some tweaks the most part it sticks
almost identical to my outline where the
point where I'm literally crossing off
scenes on my outline as soon as I
finished typing it move on to the next
one
where's the people who don't outline and
or let the characters live their own
lives they seem to meander more in the
story and as they're letting it go
wherever it wants to go well that's a
very good way it's a suddenly having a
four on a page script in front of you
and you know in that case I feel like
those people should are more geared
better towards novels you know where
they can go off and on these long
tangents that don't really connect to
the story other than they're still using
the characters so I think that's so yeah
the two different types of writers and I
find that for the most part those who
want to play God are the outliners and
those who you know let the story live
itself don't outline as much and have a
tendency of either going off on tangents
or just getting lost and not knowing
what's coming next when you talked about
how you almost thought it was a
detriment to organize your email I'm
wondering if that's actually a strength
because you like that organization and
so that that sort of lends itself to
this outline
you know cuz I do I don't do like the
like the the Blake Snyder like beat
outline like I do full scenes like I I
basically grayed out full paragraphs of
everything everything except dialogue
let's have like a really cool dialogue
that opossum head then I'll write down
the most part I my outlines are you know
they're not super long I'd say maybe
between 10 and 20 pages do you number
sorry I don't know but I do like I do a
scene heading like I know like the
locations I want these things so I still
have slugs for each of my things even in
my outline so like you know like this
scene takes place internal office and
the next Erdal house blah blah but I
don't sit there number the scenes I
don't really feel like find that super
important because one scene could be
multiple scenes once you're in script
form you know like if something is in
inside the house you could have a scene
in the living room and in the kitchen
and the dining room and it's one big one
sequence but then it's like broken down
into like three or four scenes you know
so I feel like numbering it isn't really
gonna help me much I'm still just going
to scene by scene or sequence by
sequence as it may be
anyway so yeah I don't number I don't
want to see a point what's the most
you've ever rewritten an outline revised
it I have a script James Hook
it's an origin story of Captain Hook
from Peter Pan the outline went through
about four rewrites then the script
itself went through a ton of rewrites
too because even when I finished it when
I had the outline as solid as I thought
I could get it it was like an 18 page
outline the first draft of the script
was 176 pages way too long so a lot of
stuff like got changed you know because
it was way too long and while trying to
fix how to get rid of things I started
seeing like oh well these two scenes
could be combined they weren't over here
because it seemed important they were
individual scenes but now I need it
shorter and so it's easier to just
combine these a few story elements even
you know changed along the way based on
reader notes where I was like in my head
it was like oh this is fabulous because
you're spitting so much time with the
story you may not always see everything
that is wrong with it so once I send
stuff out certain readers are like oh
this comes across this kind of racist or
this comes as sexist or this doesn't
work at all because of this thing that
happened back here that like you might
not see it as as clearly so that's why I
always get notes I always do like I do
all that line myself I don't want to
show my islands anybody and then I do my
first draft and then I do my own rewrite
on it before I sent out anybody so
nobody sees my story until it's at least
a second draft of a script and then
luckily I get very good notes to find
things that didn't occur to me even
while reading and rereading my own stuff
I feel like we have a tendency of
getting lost our own work and falling
too much in love with things and not
seeing that something doesn't work
because you love it it's such a cool
scene but sometimes those really cool
scenes are the things that aren't work
working in any capacity other than being
cool and so if you can tweak things to
make them better
you should has anyone ever tried to talk
you out of doing an outline so that you
know what traps just too much absolutely
because again I'm a serial outliner I
have I have outlined occur as right now
this today I have outlines for fourteen
features and nine pilots that I haven't
written yet so people are like why am i
spending less time and I've tried
writing without an outline before I have
two scripts that I actually did write
without outlining first and it was hell
to write them because I didn't know what
was coming next and that infuriated me
so much that I'm like I don't know how
to get these characters out of this
because I'm just trying to write
off-the-cuff you know and one of those
scripts hasn't like nothing's happened
with it and because I'm like it's it's
cool and I like it but I don't I it's
it's also very short you know like your
features should be you know like the
9220 page
in that range you know the nine to 120
and I think this script is like 82 pages
and it's because you know I'm writing it
out and like it nothing nothing there
wasn't a lot of material there of like
just coming up with the full story in
script form whereas if I if I were to
outline at first I would have seen
head-on oh my Outlands kind of short
like what else is there that needs to be
beefy you know into the story so and the
other script that I wrote without an
outline was a page quarterfinalist has
been optioned by two different producers
over the years you know so I don't
necessarily know that it's the process
not working in a script or if it's the
script networking but for me writing
both of those scripts no matter how good
one of them may have been to get option
in place in contest
it was held to write because I never
knew what was happening and had to
constantly be fixing things on the fly
where and it's much harder to fix a
problem in a 90 page script than it is
in like a 5 to 10 page outline you know
if you're outlining something it's like
10 pages and scenes need to be
rearranged you can just move scenes
around and then see how it works and
reread the whole thing again in like
what 15 20 minutes of reading to see if
it works whereas if you move something
around in a feature you could end up
leaving these behind and of course then
it's gonna affect things in the future I
would much rather rewrite you know if I
moved something near the end like it was
on page 8 of my 10 page outline and
moved to page 7 I'd rather rewrite three
pages you know as I need to rather than
in a script having to rewrite 30 pages
of stuff that because it changes
everything around it okay so it sounds
like that works because it seems like a
lot of people have an opposition to the
outlines yeah it sounds like if you
couldn't do it it was jolly hindered it
it hurts like I I feel like I know
writing is a lot of people say writing
is supposed to be hard I don't
necessarily believe that I don't find
that writing is hard if as long as you
find the time to actually write I think
it's more the issue of writing well is
hard coming up with the story that were
and again I would much rather try to
work that story out in 10 pages rather
than trying to like fix something that
was 90 pages you know I've seen I saw on
Twitter a writer recently his
professional writer works on a good TV
show who they were just trash talking
the outlining process completely and I'm
like well that's fine for you if you
don't need outline then by all means I
have another friend who refuses the
outline and her scripts are fantastic
but if you need to outline and I do
definitely outline don't listen to the
people who are trash-talking outline and
do the process that works for you
you